Speaker 1: Let's go now from Marjorie Taylor
Green to another radical ignorant Trump. I am
talking about constitutional scholar Madison. Or
just kidding, he's not a constitutional scholar,
he's actually a radical authoritarian pro
Trump congressman who said it is against the
law for airlines to require vaccines for
travel. Now, they're not doing that yet,
but I hope that they do. In fact,
we know from public opinion polls
that requiring vaccines to get on an airplane
to fly between U.S. states would be extremely
effective. And getting the anti vaccine is to go
and get a vaccination. And we're going to play a
clip in which Madison Cawthorn actually says you
have a constitutionally protected right to free,
unrestricted travel within the United
States. And it's one of those examples where
a little bit of knowledge can become a
very dangerous thing when you misunderstand
it. Let's listen to Madison Cawthorn.
Speaker 2: We should be encouraging them to
reject this. This isn't a medical apartheid,
plain and simple. There's over 100 million
Americans who are not vaccinated. And I think
it's even more than that. And if they want to
start shutting down air travel for these people
to get around the country, I think is actually
a constitutional violation because you actually
have a constitutionally protected right to free,
unrestricted travel within the United States of
America. And I genuinely believe that what's going
on right now is that all that's going to happen if
United Airlines and American Airlines and Delta,
even if they decide, start requiring vaccine
mandates. Let me tell you, I'm very confident
they will be another air carrier that will
come to the field and patriots like myself
and you will give them all of our business.
Speaker 1: Now, that last part is fine. If er
if airlines like United, American and Delta
say we're going to require vaccines, it's
completely plausible that someone else will come
forward and say we do not require vaccines. Now
if airlines are mandated to require vaccines
by the federal authority of the Department of
Transportation, then that won't happen. But if
it's a decision made by individual airlines,
Madison may well be right. Some Antibalas airline
might come forward and the Antibalas people like
Madison or whoever Grant Grant Sinkfield, they can
go and fly that. But here's where a little bit of
knowledge gets people in trouble. Madison Cathar
repeats, You have a constitutionally protected
right to free unrestricted travel within the
United States. Therefore, an airline requiring
a vaccine would be unconstitutional.
This is a really good teachable moment.
You would hope that members of Congress would
know this, but they don't. First of all, what
we're talking about here is the right to travel
domestically under constitution and the federal
law. Now, it's important to understand that it's
never been substantially questioned or limited
judicially. It's that that's absolutely true.
But in nineteen forty one, the Supreme Court
declared it unconstitutional for California
to restrict the migration of so-called Oki's
and that there is a right of free movement
as a right of national citizenship, and that
that has to be that that has been upheld under
the Commerce Clause. But there are exceptions.
There are exceptions. In a 1985 case, the
Supreme Court found that the privileges
and immunities clause prohibits discrimination
against the nonresident from us, from one state,
from another state, in one state, except where
no one. There is a substantial reason for a
different treatment. Non vaccinated status
could be such a reason. And number two,
when the discrimination practiced against
nonresident bears, a substantial relationship
to the states objective, if a state as
an objective has reduced covid spread,
you could see a limitation on the ability to
freely travel between states. But but. But more
importantly, both the president and the Department
of HHS and Governors have powers when there's
a public health emergency that can supersede the
right to travel. But throw all of that stuff away,
like forget about all of that, because there's a
bigger issue. Just because you can legally move
between states, that doesn't mean airlines have to
allow you on their flights and allow you to ignore
their requirements. What I mean by that is free
travel when it's not limited by emergencies. OK,
let's imagine there's no limitation on travel by
any governor. There's free travel. That generally
means if you can get yourself to a border of
another state, you can go into that state,
you can drive in, you can walk in, whatever. It
doesn't mean that if there's a specific airline
and a specific flight that requires vaccines,
they have to let you on. If you're not vaccinated,
imagine saying there's free travel between states.
I don't have to be subjected to TSA security
because the Constitution grants me free
travel between states. Come on, guys,
get in a car and drive over there. But that can't
be used to say you get to skip security. And along
the same lines, as long as vaccine requirements
are generally legal for airlines to put in place,
which as far as we know right now, they are. It
is just as legal for an airline as a policy to
say we require proof of vaccination for passengers
or we require proof of vaccination for employees
or both, they really don't get it. But they
come up with stuff that to lower information
news consumers. Sounds good. Hey, I do have
a right to free travel between states by the
Constitution. Sure. Get in the car and drive
over there. And assuming the road's not closed
and assuming if it's a toll road that you
pay the toll. Right. All of these things,
if you can get yourself to the border, you
can go in. That doesn't mean you get to go
to an airline and say, I'm not abiding by any
of your rules. I'm not wearing my seatbelt. I'm
going to be standing during takeoff. I don't
want to go through security and I don't want
to be vaccinated. It's just not the way it
works. And unfortunately, Madison Cawthorn
continues to convince people with this stuff.
He's admitted he's not running a policy office.
He's running a PR and communications office. And
this stuff gets millions and millions of views.
And his followers love it. It's all B.S.. It's
all wrong, conveys a complete misunderstanding
of what it means to have free travel between
states, but his followers absolutely love it.